what better way to begin 2018 than by
looking at what Souls like games will be
coming out so let me show you the five
games that are on my radar and should be
on yours if you're big Souls born fan
and looking for more of that kind of
content number one is the truest entry
on this list as it's really more of a
continuation of the souls born franchise
than is just a Souls life made by the
creators of Dark Souls shadows die twice
which actually probably isn't the name
of the game the first game to be on the
lookout for while all we have is a
teaser and it's not good to get too
height off of just a teaser this comes
directly from from software so it's safe
to assume a pretty high quality product
and we also know from soft is working on
a game that will meet the expectations
of souls fans and this looks like it
could very well be it we don't know a
lot about it but we can tell that it
will have a pretty dark mood and it
looks like a medieval Eastern maybe
Japanese setting if you want to see more
go check out my teaser breakdown I
expect from to release some more
information on the game sometime soon as
they have said to be on the lookout for
new information in the coming months
shadows die twice could very well be a
proper soul style game and such a game
coming from the creators of Dark Souls
themselves assuredly deserves the
attention of souls fans at number two
next up is Bandai Namco's attempt to
hold on to the souls popularity through
their game code vein if you don't know
Bandai Namco is the company that
published Dark Souls but I do not
believe they're publishing From
Software's future games an anime vampire
Souls like Cobain will probably have a
decent triple-eight production and do at
least a decent job of capturing
difficult gameplay any Souls like
fashion but we've yet to be given any
reason to think that we can expect
serious innovation or uniqueness in code
vain the companion system could be an
avenue for Bandai Namco to pursue this
kind of ingenuity but we'll have to wait
until we are given more information
and/or gameplay to really decide this
the companion system could be a really
unique feature that lets this game shine
and differentiate itself from Dark Souls
a Dark Souls very much did not have a
core companion feature past co-op so I'm
not necessarily excited for this game
but it could develop into something
worthwhile and standalone which warrants
keeping an eye on it as the
year progresses at third we have ashen
which is probably the biggest departure
from traditional souls like on this list
so far it has a dark but somewhat
cartoony art style and purports to have
a big focus on multiplayer co-op and NPC
interaction the game also seems to have
more in the story development than souls
generally does at least that's what I
got from the trailer which is a welcome
difference the games website talks about
choosing which NPC to trust and bringing
back those that you do trust to your
camp and trying to survive together
mechanics like this being fully fleshed
out would really give this game its own
personality and I hope to see a focus on
these when the game comes out the game
looks like it does a great job of
creating a gloomy mysterious atmosphere
which juxtaposes nicely with the after
mention cartoony art style the game
already looked pretty unique from its
art design so we can probably expect a
continuation of this differentiation in
the rest of the game a Souls like that
innovates and stands on its own merits
is essentially the ideal of this
quote-unquote
genre and action being a candidate of
this makes it very worthy of being kept
on the radar now the last two games I
want to talk about aren't really souls
like in any way shape form however I
think that souls players could very well
find them pretty enjoyable and they
share quite a few similarities to the
genre of souls life so I thought it made
sense to add also there aren't a lot of
other proper Souls like that are very
noteworthy that said let's talk about
number four Monster Hunter World the
first entry in the series to have proper
large Western release unfortunately it
looks like it'll be on consoles first
and won't come to PC until later but the
game still looks great as the name
implies it's largely about hunting
monsters which includes a complex system
of preparation of supplies and tools and
weapons there are very fantastical
settings and what looks like to be wide
range combat situations and movement
choices the game is releasing soon this
January so we'll quickly be able to see
how it holds up unfortunately I wasn't
able to play any of the beta so I can
only make comments from the trailers but
it looks like if you're able to get past
the initial overwhelmingness of all the
manageable features a worthwhile and
quality experience awaits if the
gameplay is even half decent the games
are too
and very locations should allow a good
time to be had and that makes it worth
looking out for lastly we have a remake
of an old classic Shadow of the Colossus
the original is amazingly acclaimed and
has a third-person action-adventure game
with a focus on fighting bosses with
medieval setting weapons
I hope it's understandable why this got
an inclusion in the video the new remake
is supposed to faithfully recreate the
original but the only changes being the
graphics and visuals Department
developers have said that they've
recreated most of the assets from the
ground up to really solidify the quality
and the lack of change to the actual
gameplay in design of the game means
that the remake should recapture the
original magic - a fairly strong extent
and bring this classic game to a new
generation the game is expansive
completely devoid of enemies except for
the bosses the sprawling vistas are
looking pretty amazing in the trailer
videos I don't want to go into too much
more detail as the less you know the
better when starting the game my opinion
and there are also a plethora of reviews
already as the game came out over 10
years ago so you should be able to
decide pretty well if it's worth it to
keep this game in mind so heading into
2018 that is my list there are surely
other great games and other genres that
should be kept on your radar like Red
Dead Redemption - for example but these
are what I've seen as the top contenders
for satisfying that souls itch thanks
for watching and have a swaggy day